hello everyone my name is dr. Miller and
the SCP were going to be looking at
today is SCP 1146 object class safe
special containment procedures SCP 1146
is to be stored in a standard sized
containment chamber due to SCP 1146 is
ability to connect to networks it is not
to be allowed contact with any form of
external connection and may only be
allowed access to closed on-site
networks for the purposes of testing in
the event of site transfer SCP 1146 must
clearly be marked as such to prevent
accidental refilling of filament
material no staff are to attempt to
refill SCP 11 46 is filament material
under any circumstances description SCP
11 46 appears to be a heavily modified
brand 3d printer modifications include a
40 point 6 centimeter LCD screen a set
of small speakers an enlarged printing
bay and a number of wires exposed along
various points of the subjects case
through means currently unknown as CP 11
46 seems to lack any requirement for an
exterior power source and can continue
operating after being unplugged after a
short delay though no means of opening
the object had been found x-ray imaging
has been used to reveal a lack of
internal components SCP 1146 was
recovered from an abandoned office
building Russia after a series of
reports involving living statues after a
search by agents as CP 11 46 was found
in the building surrounded by a number
of various creatures and objects the
device was transported to site where it
currently resides as CP 11 46 is
anomalous attributes are exhibited when
a human being comes within 5 meters the
attached screen will automatically turn
on and will display a blue oscilloscope
it will begin to yell insults at the
individual in the voice of a Russian
child or tried to convince them to fix a
filament blockage as long as SCP 1146
remains without filament material and no
biological material over one kilogram
and mass is placed in the filament bay
this is the extent of its anomalous
abilities if SCP 1146 does have filament
it will begin event SCP 1146 one during
event SCP 1146 one the subject will
begin yelling louder and louder and its
oscilloscope will change from blue to
purple
it will begin printing a number of
creatures referred to as a CP 1146 one
collectively including oversized and
dennis Imperator Velociraptor Mongolian
says then this process takes
approximately 45 seconds per model and
appears to be merely an accelerated
version of the standard printing process
the models display characteristics of
the biological material upon which the
filament is based with an apparent
preference for animal muscular and bone
tissue upon completion each model will
exit the printing Bay and attack any
human it encounters the models ranging
in size from 6 centimeters to 50
centimeters have a lifespan of
approximately 30 minutes after which
they will fit refine the models are
susceptible to gunfire and can also be
destroyed by an extreme blunt force or
temperatures capable of destroying the
base material as CP 11 46 will continue
producing models until it reaches 50%
filament after which it will begin a
vent as CP 11 46 - if it is managed to
produce at least 5 models otherwise it
will attempt to re-enter its dormant
state if sep11 46 manages to produce 5
models it will begin a vent as CP 11 46
- during this process the models will
attempt to move sep11 to 46 - an exit
attacking any on-site personnel on route
SCP 1146 will produce additional models
as needed and will create models and
increasingly dangerous items and animals
as it moves as CP 1146 will continue
this behavior until it runs out of
filament at which point it will enter a
dormant state and can safely be
transported back to its containment cell
in the event that one kilogram or more
of biological material is placed into
the filament access SCP 1146 will begin
event SCP 1146 3 during this process the
organic material is pulled into SCP
11:46
through its filament access slot and is
violently crushed into a thick paste in
the event that the object is larger than
SCP 1146 it will consume as much of the
sample as it can and abandon the rest
upon finishing event SCP 1146 to SCP
1146 will re-enter its dormant state
unless there is a human within a 5 meter
radius in which case and will begin
event SCP 1146 1
the following are archived containment
procedures from January 16th 2003 CP
1146 object class safe special
containment procedures SCP 1146 is to be
stored in a standard size containment
chamber d2 SCP 1146 is friendly nature
and in mobile state only a single lock
door is required for containment a
single guard of a social nature should
be posted to keep si P 1146 company on a
weekly rotation only personnel who have
submitted a formal application for
testing with SCP 1146 and received
approval may operate as CP 1146
description SCP 1146 appears to be a
heavily modified brand printer
modifications include a 40 point 6
centimeter LCD screen a set of small
speakers and a large printing Bay and a
number of wires jutting from the
subjects case as the device lacks any
form of opening in its case x-ray
imaging has been used to reveal a lack
of internal components SCP 1146 was
recovered from an abandoned office
building in Russia after a series of
reports involving living statues after a
search by agents SCP 1146 was found in
the building surrounded by a number of
models and various creatures and objects
the device was transported to site where
it currently resides as CP 11 46 is
anomalous attributes are exhibited when
a human being comes within 5 meters of
the device the attached screen will
automatically turn on displaying a green
oscilloscope and greeting the person in
the voice of a Russian child the device
will then identify itself as Alexei and
will then ask the person what they would
like to do at that point the person can
merely chat with a subject or request
that it make a model
chatting what the subject is limited to
subjects understood by most children
such as children's stories and toys
although the printer does not seem to be
bound to these topics it seems to be
capable of learning and has been taught
small amounts of English and Spanish
since arriving its son if the device is
asked to produce a model it will request
that it is brought to an image of the
desired model though means currently
unknown it will look at the image and
begin creating it most models take
approximately 45 seconds to finish the
process appearing to be an accelerated
version of that of a normal printer of
the same name once completed the model
will animate and exit the printing Bay
of its own accord the completed models
are of a playful demeanor and are
completely safe for handling the models
will have a lifespan of approximately 30
minutes after which the models will
undergo vitrification and turn into a
regular 3d printed sculpture because of
SCP 1146 is possible sentience all level
2 and above research staff may request
permission for testing SCP 1146 is
intelligence and modeling dr. SCP 1146
testing law note to all researchers
please include your name request and the
results into your testing log also
please ensure you remove all created
models from the testing chamber when
you're finished
test one name dr. grant request one
model of a cube result SCP 1146 quickly
turned out the cube
although expressing boredom in the
simplicity of the model the model
remained inanimate and was removed with
no problems the complete cube can now be
found on dr. grants desk in use as a
paperweight test to name dr. grant
request one model of a tiger result SCP
1146 expressed concern at how dangerous
a real tiger would be whilst working
when completed the model walked down to
the machine and curled up at dr. Grant's
feet seemingly taking a nap as CP 1146
expressed happiness at the cute behavior
of the tiger the model eventually stood
up and wandered around the testing
chamber and vitrified after 28 minutes
interesting it appears that the models
only come to life if they are models of
living things it also seems that the SCP
affects how the model behaves I'll have
to see if this is the case dr. Grandin
test three named dr. grant request one
model of a piranha result as CP 11 46
quickly printed the fish talking about
how it likes sea creatures upon
completion the printed model was dropped
into a fish tank and then exposed to a
sample of human blood
no reaction was observed the model
instead behaving like a common goldfish
upon being questioned if it had ever
seen a fish before SCP 11 46 confirmed
that his Creator had a pet fish it seems
that the behavior of the models is
indeed based on how the SCP believes
they should act I wonder to what extent
this independent will of the Machine
goes dr. grant
tests for name research assistant
requests one model of female result SCP
1146 requested a picture which was
provided and completed the model
commenting on it being a very
strange-looking cat research assistant
proceeded to security team be assisted
in removal and research assistant was
treated for severe blood loss amputation
and deep tissue scratches before being
terminated it wait what that is this
really lessens my faith in my fellow man
still it does provide some rather
valuable data this confirms that the
behavior of the models is decided by the
SCP and is based completely on how the
Machine believes the models should act
I suppose it's actually kind of lucky
that we like to use slang however I hope
that 1146 isn't disturbed by this event
dr. grant
test five named dr. Owens prior to this
test the subject was exposed to a
Russian dub of the children's show
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles request one
model of a turtle result instead of
requesting an image of a turtle as CP
1146 began printing while humming the
cartoons theme song the completed model
was a rendition of the cartoon
characters the model began leaping
around the test chamber whilst
performing several styles of martial art
subject expressed glee at the behavior
of the model model vitrification at 27
minutes building off dr. Grant's work it
appears that the subject does indeed
control the behavior of the models based
upon preconceptions of their behavior it
also appears that the SCP does not
require an image to create something it
has already seen this may require a
small amount of extra testing but I'm
quite sure of it dr. Owens test 6 named
dr. Owens request one model of dr. grant
result SCP 1146 immediately began
speaking of how kind
dr. grant had treated it whilst
immediately beginning to print a
likeness of him the completed model
walked around the testing chamber
appearing to take notes on a clipboard
model vitrification after 37 minutes as
previously hypothesized the subject does
not require an image of a model to
reproduce it if it has previously
observed it this may prove useful in the
event that the foundation ever needs to
create a likeness of an individual or an
SCP dr. Owens
due to recent events all testing of SCP
1146 is to be halted immediately
transcript 11 46 16 January 14th 2000
and this is a CP 11 46 your current
assignment ages said a lot now we're
going to quickly demonstrate how 1146
works hello Alexei we would like you to
make us a cat what how can that even a
liqu Alex let the doctor go
you killed my friend Alex what was I
supposed to do on January 16th 2005
sep11 46 began creating additional
models before security teams could
respond the models had breached
containment and began transporting SCP
1146 out of the facility 14 psych and
security staff were killed before all
models were neutralized SCP 1146 was
found attached to an Ethernet cable on
level 2 all cyclic computers received
the following email originally in
Russian but the English translation
reads I hate you all
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to albino Neku James Saba Andre bishop
Jax Merrick Pablo ice 917 Burlington the
cat all the time gaming Justin day
researcher bull Vere Pierce M Hamlin
Curie kuma white crew Nicholas James vu
Jack
Bryce and Billy my archive curator Nick
cootie tench the Android slump god
quartz 5 6 3 I'm tree hero thank you all
so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you